[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George Campbell joined
by my good friend Ken Coleman this is
your show America we are here for you to
help you take the right next step with
your money with your work and with your
life the number to call is
5225 I'd be happy to chime in on your
money questions and Ken he is the work
career purpose guy if you feel stuck you
feel like you're not doing what you want
to do you feel like you could be making
more money you're not sure how to have
that conversation with your boss or your
coworker Ken is an expert at walking you
through those predicaments and so we're
happy to take your call 8825
5225 Matt joins us up first in Raleigh
Matt what is going on my friend how are
you doing
today good how are you good how can we
help uh so me and my wife we've been
together for about five years married
for two um we just found out a little
bit ago that we are expecting and she's
about 15 weeks so we've kind of made
some changes in um kind of our spending
habits and being able to save up for uh
when our child is due uh one of the
things that came up was uh saving for
college um which I'm able to provide
that I'm in the military and I'm
actually going to be passing along my
911 GI bill which is a full ride
scholarship for that child great
wonderful other uh thing that the other
thing that we were looking at was a
custodial brokerage account when the
child is born um me and my wife have
been kind of talking about it uh doing
$100 a month until they're 18 the only
thing is is my wife is concerned that
much money when our child turns 18 is
going to be too much um I kind of did
the math $100 with a 10% rate of return
by the time they're 18 they'll have
53,000 um just trying to get an Insight
if that's too much money
or well I I personally don't think so if
you just look at the you know inflation
and what things could cost 20 years from
now I I don't think it would be a waste
to be Investing For Your kids' future
whether it's in a custodial brokerage
account or a 529 plan that has tax
advantages or an education savings
account yeah so we look at the 529 um we
we we think we aren't going to go that
route just because I'm able to pass
along my post 911 GI bill um it's a full
ride scholarship uh and includes housing
as well oh great so expenses are 100%
covered and what would the custodial
brokerage account be for
then uh more of just having a saving
account uh from what I looked at they
once they turn 18 it goes into their
possession and they can do whatever they
want with it um I me personally I've
never inherited anything uh from my
parents uh all the uh income and savings
that I have I've uh me and my wife have
done it together and so it's just more
of way to get a head start for our child
um that way they don't feel like when
they turn 18 that they're on their
own well I I don't think you could have
too much then I've never heard a parent
go well they had too much to set them up
and get the car and get the down payment
on the house I think whatever you put in
there is going to be an amazing blessing
and you guys have done a great job
already gotcha gotcha so $100 is not too
much even it doesn't sound like it's
putting you guys out to put away 1,200
bucks a year is it
no no me me and my wife I mean we make
um a little over 990,000 I already have
uh 38,000 in a Roth IRA are you doing
15% uh so I'm doing 10% and the military
matches four or 5% the only difference
is my 10% is rth and the 5% is
traditional yes okay I would still up
your percentage to 15% and so if you're
investing 15% of $90,000 you're putting
away some money for college then you're
attacking the house that puts you right
in line with these baby steps that have
helped so many people build
wealth gotcha so if you can still do all
of that with a hundred bucks left over
to uh put away I think your your kid
will be very happy at that surprise and
I think you're going to raise a great
kid that's not entitled cuz that's
always the fear Ken is you go here's a
pile of money don't ruin your life but I
think if you raise your kid the right
way with the right mindset around
college and adulthood they're not going
to going to ruin their life they're
going to say thank you for helping set
me up for success and to that end and to
that end Matt I I don't know that I
would reveal to the child that this
money is coming I'd almost make this uh
a surprise on their 18th birthday and
and raise them in a in a uh way that
they don't know that that money is
sitting there and so they develop grit
they develop hard work they don't have
that sense of entitlement that would be
my only thing I'd be a great awesome
surprise but I would not reveal it early
cuz you know listen who Among Us doesn't
change our gear you know when if you
know 50 Grand is coming up why would you
work that part-time job for three years
what do you think about that I in fact I
I didn't have a strong opinion on that
until you said surprise you said be a
great surprise and that made me think I
don't know that I would tell the kid
well there's a few schools of thought
you know Dave did the 401 Dave plan with
his kids when it came to saving up for a
car and so he true he would match so I
think it's good but that's for the car
I'm talking about this is like you know
they they don't have access to their 18
yes so presumably we got the car
beforehand yeah what do you think George
I like to hold off on
it there's no reason to I mean they're
going to avoid debt and so it's okay to
have a string attached and go listen
this is the caveat is we're not touching
debt you will not take out any debt if
you do the The Situation's going to
change and right now with college
they're not
going well yeah and that's the thing is
I mean the college is paid for now if we
have a second kid all right then only
half their college is paid for because
I'm going to be splitting up evenly and
if we do have a second child um that
that's what I was kind of telling
towards my wife is I mean if they had
$50,000 they'd be able to go to college
and not have any debt and possibly even
leave college with some of that money
still left
over yeah man I think you're you're
making the wise decision because you've
got the GI bill and the the cool thing
is with the secure 2.0 act you can roll
over a portion of funds from a 529 into
a Roth IRA over time and so it's not a
quote waste a lot of people just go well
I'm not going to save for college
because what if they don't go what
happens is the kid doesn't have the
money to go they take out six figures in
student loans and then there's trapped
with payments so I love that you guys
are thinking through this in a really
Wise Way Matt and I think this kids
they're obviously going to go to college
debt free but the better thing is
they're going to learn money management
at an early
age yeah and that that's the goal that's
the goal I love it well hey thank you
for your service Matt and uh yes what an
inspiring story to see at least one more
student becoming a student without a
student loan it is possible and
sometimes it's the the GI Bill through
the military it's one of the great
benefits if you're a service member and
you you're able to go to school debt
free or your children are able to go to
school debt free and not have that
burden of student loans what an
incredible way to set your kid up Ken to
not be in Chains when they graduate cuz
then no matter what job they have they
feel broke that's right cuz they got
payments all around them and I'm one of
these guys that's holding out hope I'll
be misty eyed when the day arrives
George I think it's going to happen when
we see the current higher red situation
uh just completely broken up and we see
the cost of getting educated back down
to way more feasible true Roi on the
amount of money people are spending and
we see the student loan crisis Gone
Forever That's My Hope amen it's supply
and demand let's just stop paying these
colleges exorbitant amounts of money
exactly this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial peace and you don't see
any way out you need y refi they're not
a debt settlement company and they're
not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumpsum payoff option you could qualify
for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Ken Coleman this
hour the number is
8825 5225 don't be shy don't be scared
give us a call we'll walk you through
why would you be scared of us people are
frightened Ken very intimidated by well
because of the live you know kind of on
the air business business but if you
look at us two I mean you couldn't be
less scarier of two guys but if you
can't see us you only hear us you think
wow these guys must be intimidating no
I'm pretty sure that when anybody hears
you they're not intimidated my bar tone
maybe but yours kind of a mousy
tener kind of a honey soaked tener if
you will oh honey soaked I like that
dude that's good well Jack's not scared
he called jack is not let's see what
Jack's got going my hometown oh yeah
Boston Boston Massachusetts let's go
Jack how you doing
hey doing well guys thanks for taking my
call sure how can we
help um I had a quick question here I'm
trying to figure out if I should sell or
keep my condo my primary residence where
I'm at now I recently found out the
condo association hasn't been really
managed that well over the past 15 years
or so um I've been here for about eight
but I just found out that um there's
about $3 million worth of damages on the
property in terms of like roofs that
need to be replaced and siding and um
rot and things like that possibly mold
but they're not sure yet there's about
like 15 buildings on the property that
need to be you know fixed and everything
and repaired um they did have a guy come
on site and do a full evaluation
assessment of the property and
documented all the damage that he found
but I'm just trying to figure out how
much of an increase in an HOA fee is too
much to the point where as an owner I
should probably think about selling my
property or or just staying put um
considering how much uh home prices have
appreciated over the years and the high
interest rates with mortgages and I
would certainly be taking on more debt
than the current mortgage that I have
now which is at about
120,000 that I owe currently so 120,000
on the mortgage and once this these
damages are divvied out among all of the
uh homeowners what do you think it'll be
right around $30,000 if I were to pay it
out of pocket up front and what is the
stipulations can you just pay it over
time with no penalty but you can't sell
the condo without paying the
fee right Pro I'm sure that's probably
how it would work they're not there yet
they still need to get quotes and
everything um like that that $3 million
Mark is just the preliminary company
that came in they want to get quotes
from three others before they take
action yeah o and so what's your current
HOA fee
right now uh they just bumped it up to
500 and next year so like by the end of
this year hopefully they should have a
plan in place to repair the damages
that's their goal the board um and they
had like a projection increase over the
next 20 years it would be a 20-year loan
that they would take out most likely to
do the repairs um and it would the HOA
would max out around the 15year mark So
somewhere around like 20 30 something um
it would be up around
$725 it would cap out at um but next
year it would be around 600 but this
year we're at the $500 Mark got it so
we're talking about an increase of 1,200
bucks a year potentially and then
eventually 2400 bucks a year plus but
that kind of caps out you're not going
to be paying $2,000 in HOA
fees no okay so that's what we're
talking about here I just like to put
numbers on it to give me some real facts
uh cuz this does stink and it happens
all over and you're right a lot of HOAs
are not managed well
and things like this happen and it gets
passed on to the homeowners of course so
not fun to deal with but this is part of
uh part of life as a homeowner you get
to deal with so what is your
mortgage outside of the HOA fee what is
that it up
to uh like the monthly payment yes it's
about $888 principal and interest okay
and then what is your take-home pay
after
taxes per
month um take home I think I'm right
around maybe 3,300 okay so as a
percentage of your income that mortgage
plus the HOA it's taken up a good
chunk right you know when you look at
1388 out of 3,300 it's 42% of your take
home pay right now is going toward this
house and so as that goes up you know it
could creep up to 50% of your income is
going toward this house which is then
going to be hard to invest for the
future hard to live your life are you
feeling that pain right
now um not so much right now um I'm I'm
pretty Frugal I try to save as much as I
can um but I'm definitely concerned
about the future especially as the HOA
fee creeps up to 600 by 2025 potentially
yeah well here's the thing when you put
numbers to it and you add this into your
budget the extra you know 50 bucks a
month they're going to start charging is
not going to crush you that's 600 bucks
a
year
correct correct so it's not fun to pay
the extra 600 bucks a year than 800
bucks a year but it's not it's not worth
let's go ahead and sell the condo today
cuz you might have to deal with more HOA
fees and higher HOA fees elsewhere if
you went and sold and bought another
property especially in the Boston area
cuz my brother's got a condo in the
Boston area and he he knows this life
wealth these are some old condos that
have not been taken care of very
well so Jack if I'm in your shoes I'm
going to hold off is what I'm telling
you right now it's not worth it to save
600 bucks a year I would rather you go
make more money so how can we get your
income up to where this isn't as big of
an
issue what are you doing for work um
yeah I work in at a health insurance
company okay how long you been
there um I've been there about two years
okay are you making around 50k what is
the actual gross
salary so the actual grow salary and I
might have messed up the take-home pay
figure there um after taxes but I gross
about 80k a year oh great that's good
what's promotion look like for
you um that's a little bit uncertain at
the moment the company's kind of going
through a restructure um so I might be
at that salary for a little bit while
okay longer well and again but you're a
young man and you've got you got plenty
of option plenty of energy and to
George's point at this season of your
life uh that that gig you know the gig
economy right now where people are using
their professional skill set which you
have plenty uh to make um money on the
side you know and contract labor uh look
you know that's the way you get more
margin right now and if you want more
margin go get it you know and you may
get to a certain point you go okay I'll
do it for six months I'll do it for 12
months I'll do it for 18 months to save
x amount of dollars it's not a bad idea
if you've got the margin relationally to
to be able to do it yeah and Jack when
you do if you did choose to sell you got
to also think about the fees that you're
going to pay to sell it the fees you're
going to pay to buy a new condo moving
cost so there's a lot of other figures
to factor in that I think would outweigh
the extra 600 bucks you're going to pay
in the next year so down the line if you
want to move because of other reasons
you can move but I would stay put for
now but what do you think is going to
happen on the other side of the
improvements if he stays like you and I
agree with you he should stay but I
think he benefits I mean sure he's going
to pay more in HOA but then you know if
he sells it down the road I would
imagine he's improvements are going to
help his sales price you would hope one
would hope especially in the Boston area
and I'm sure even in the eight years
Jack you've been there the condo
appreciated correct correct yep so
that's a win right there I like that's
the other thing I was going to mention I
like the uh benefit of the improvements
if you hold like George says and I think
George is right for every point he makes
but I'd add that to it you're going to
benefit from that you know think of it
as an investment in your uh resale value
and even paying the you know 1,300 total
with HOA and mortgage that's still
pretty reasonable for a Metro City like
Boston incred to have your own place so
you you've done this really a smart Jack
and I'm proud of you for living on less
than you make that's the key to this
whole thing do you have any
debt I don't no I just paid off um 33
Grand over the summer for my student
loans go Jack way to go man how's that
feel it felt awesome yeah it was pretty
sweet you got an emergency fund as well
3 to six months I do yeah great and
you're investing in retirement plans yep
look at that I have one more question
Jack are you born and raised or or been
in the Boston area a long
time no I'm well I grew up in the uh New
Hampshire area so North of Boston by
about an hour right still a New
Englander the reason I ask is because
you and George both you'd never know
that you've lived a long time in that
area I'm pretty impressed with the lack
of access we lose it Ken We Are
chameleons we can bring it up when we
want to give me an example take us to
break in in Boston Bostonian dude you've
been to the Red Sox game dude is wicked
sick dude poppy just smashed one to the
to the green
monster you actually you actually have
to know about baseball to finish that
but it was good almost lost it at green
monster that you got to get for Fen
monster this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian healthc Care Ministries a
health cost sharing Ministry but listen
to Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Ken Coleman and
Ken and I are going to be at a brand new
event that we've got coming up May 10th
and 11th right here in Nashville
Tennessee called Total Money Makeover
weekend I know there's millions of you
out there you've been listening for a
while maybe you're still sitting on the
sidelines well no more sitting around
you got to take action so in just one
weekend you're going to get a crash
course on everything we teach about
money we've got all brand new content
new talks from all of the Ramsey
personalities including Dave Ramsey on
budgeting beating debt investing making
more money and so much more so no matter
what baby step you're on if you're just
getting started maybe you're even at
baby step 7 and you're looking for ways
to build wealth and give generously this
event will light a fire under your butt
to keep going to keep making progress
we've also got some special things
happening during the event we've we' got
a live smart money happy hour recording
on Friday night that'll be a blast we've
got live Q&A throughout the weekend
which is one of my favorite things to
witness from our friend Ken Coleman when
he Dives in with one person in the crowd
it is magic so you don't want to miss
this our events are actually fun these
are not boring we've got musical
experiences our team is world class so
early bird tickets start at just 99
bucks but they're going to keep going up
this is the cheapest you're going to
find them so get your tickets now
ramseys solutions.com events and make
plans to join us Nashville Tennessee May
10th and 11th ramsy solutions.com events
and we're kicking around some fun ideas
you know that may or may not make it you
know is this you pitching to get on
Smart money happy hour well I've already
done that I already did that last week
and I'm not going to pitch it again so
you brought it up but that's what people
want I knew it was ruminating in that
little I've got another idea that you
and I you know a lot of guys uh don't
care what they wear their wives care
what they wear what if we had a special
bonus session you and I lead it couples
only and we we kind of help help the
wives out and we call it total clothing
makeover and the wives will volunteer
their husbands to parade on stage and we
will judge their fashion and give them
some tips Yeah so basically content uh
we'll give them tips and then you'll
help them do it on a budget this is
actually good Ken we start with delone
we could start with start with thank you
James everybody knows that guy needs a
total clothing makeover I mean first of
all would it kill him to dress like a
doctor I think we all have that teenager
that dresses like deloney in our lives
you know but list I I I actually make no
fun of it cuz you know what the guy
doesn't have to make a lot of decisions
that's true you and I on the other hand
we're stewing every morning which
cardigan are we going to throw on this
morning hey I haven't rocked a cardigan
in a while but you know what I'll do it
next time we're on together just so you
can take shots at it oh that's fun we
have a good time we do we enjoy it and
we're going to have a good time helping
people out who's up next well it's time
for the neighborly question of the day
oh the neighborly question of the day
that's right yeah don't get too excited
this is a really good one I'm excited to
get your input so then Ramsey question
of the day brought to you by neighborly
your hub for Home Services neighborly
docomo you can download their winter
maintenance checklist completely free
and full of tips to get your home
through the colder months with no issues
again you can check it out at neighborly
docomo I was destitute and owed $115,000
to the IRS I raised my kids by myself
with no contribution from my ex-wife I
followed your teachings and I'm now debt
free with money in savings and
Investments I'm retired and living very
frugally but I'm terrified of being
destitute again my weekly grocery budget
is am I reading this right
$35 I don't use the AC in the summer and
won't turn on the heat in the winter
this is from Billy in
Indiana uh he turns it on when it gets
below freezing yikes I've taken all the
light bulbs but one out of all the
fixtures in the house I take three
minute showers and haven't eaten out in
two years
how do I live without my phobia of being
broke again man this is intense but I
but let me just
say destitute it's a heavy word the kids
young stories behind I know what that
word means but it takes down and out to
a new level and I think that um him
having nothing at all so seared his
conscience yeah I mean this is as much
emotional relational as it is financial
I do and I think therapy I think this is
some I think I would get some therapy on
this to be able to create a
narrative that
is uh in opposition to the voice of fear
because the voice of fear is rooted in
tremendous pain George and so you've got
to counteract that this again delone is
not here but the bottom line is this is
a form of
OCD and and OCD is anxiety and I'm not
in any way diagnosing him with OCD but
I'm saying it feels like he's so
obsessed with saving money that you're
talking about $35 a week not using the
air conditioning I've seen this episode
of extreme cheap skates these people do
not have thrilling joyful lives they're
terrified they're terrified and so I
would start with I think Ken spot on
here uh Billy you need to go to therapy
and deal with the past and a good start
is reading our friend Dr John delon's
book your past change your future
because you're not there anymore you're
doing well now and so we tell people to
make a budget and actually look at how
much margin you have and force yourself
to go out and eat once a week force
yourself to go be generous we found that
generosity can unlock something when it
comes to that destitute mindset and it
will make you have an open hand when it
comes to money so I would start to give
save spend in each area you're great at
saving and that muscle has been flexed
but you got to flat tire when it comes
to giving and spending so I would
increase both of those force it in your
budget and the other thing I would do is
get people around you you sound like
you're isolated like you're living like
a recluse start making some Community
get plugged into a local church hang out
with family and friends that's going to
help you break out of this yeah I agree
I mean this is just overcoming the
trauma and then beginning to uh get the
tools to get over it but then then you
got to take some steps and go okay what
if what if if I spend $150 a week on
groceries is it going to tank you no can
you but but I think the fear is so great
here that even seeing it on paper I
don't know that that's going to solve it
stair step it we're going to spend 40
bucks this week 45 the next week until
you're spending a reasonable amount I
mean this sounds like it's affecting
your health yeah if you're living in a
34 Degree house eating literal rice and
beans that's frightening so uh Billy
we're we're wishing you the best man but
you got to take some steps to knock
yourself out of this Vortex sorry to
hear you going through that
all right let's go to the phones Janice
is in Orlando Janice welcome to the
Ramsey
Show hi hey thank you for taking my call
sure um to give you some background well
I'm 58 years old divorced I work
fulltime um I have no debt I Janice
Janice sorry to interrupt you could you
maybe adjust your phone your sound a bit
muffled oh okay who's better a little
bit better
go ahead okay so 58 divorce you're
working
full-time yes no debt um I have an
emergency fund so I'm currently saving
for retirement as well um the problem is
I currently rent out a studio and um
with rents increasing the way they have
been I'm getting a little nervous and
I'm wondering if at 58 is
that
um is that a good age to make purchase a
condo um I don't want to get into a
situation where the rents get too high
and I'm not able to pay it basic I think
now is a great time if you have the
money and you I think now is a great
time if you have the money and you can
put down the down payment and you're
able to cover this mortgage it's no more
than a quarter of your take-home pay
that's how you know you're making a
right decision but I think you're right
i' would rather you have a fixed cost
and pay off that house so that you can
retire with dignity
without these Rising costs of rent
weighing you down in
retirement so where how much money do
you have saved outside of the emergency
fund um outside well the emergency fund
I have 30k okay and but you haven't
started on the down payment
savings um no okay I would begin there
how much money can you put away every
month for this down payment
now well um see um I have uh 30k in in
my emergency phone which may be a little
too much um total um money that I have
is uh the last time I checked which was
two days ago
117,000 um is that in retirement though
or is that liquid cash in the bank
that's everything um 30 is liquid and
then the rest is uh split between a
401k okay I don't want you touching
those retirement accounts we need to
build up money outside of that with
future income and so that's what I would
do increase your income put that money
aside when you're ready reach out to a
Ramsey trusted real estate agent at
Ramsey solutions.com and we're wishing
you the best with the home ownership
[Music]
Journey if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com and
save up to 35% off everything sitewide
that's blinds.com to learn more
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Ken Coleman if
you like this show be sure to check out
all of the shows in the Ramsey Network
including the Ken Coleman show Which
films right next door to the Ramsey Show
which is fun and of course uh the smart
money happy hour I co-host with Rachel
Cruz and my YouTube channel we're having
a good time over there Ken breaking
records around here people are enjoying
the YouTube content well I me your
team's doing a great job and and you
obviously are are really great for that
quick snippy you know entertaining
you're just perfect for YouTube that
means the world I think I'm being
serious well I've got a face for radio
and I think YouTube is the next best
place for people who don't have a the
face you know you can make it as a
YouTuber out there you don't have to be
good-look you just got to be good that's
the best encouragement I could ask for
from Ken Coleman today I like that I
think you're a good-looking guy I you're
I'm trying to compliment you here you're
you're you're what I'm not fishing for
compliments I know you're not but I'm
just saying I'm not surprised that the
Channel's doing great I think it's
fantastic very happy for you we have a
great team here all right let's get to
the phones before we get in a massive
fight CJ break this up my friend how can
we help you
today hey George hey Ken um so I'm a 21y
old and I've just accumulated about
$90,000 from a sign on bonus uh for
becoming a professional baseball player
and I my goal is I'm just trying to
maximize this money and kind of set
myself up for you know an an easy easier
road down the line nice so I just don't
really have a starting point and I just
want to get some advice for what to do
with this money congrats yeah okay so
let's talk about you said you're
19 uh 21 21 okay 21 years old this is
the most money you've ever seen in your
life I
imagine yeah it's uh it's more than I
know what to do with for sure good it
should take your breath away just a
little bit not cause you to go in
paralysis mode but enough to pause and
go breathe now
breath every time I see it let's so so
is it in your savings account right
now it is it's just sitting there okay
okay cool so let's talk through your
financial situation um do you have any
debt no I'm I'm debt free nice emergency
fund three to six
months yep that's a it's included within
that wonderful okay so you already have
no debt in a pile of money in the bank
regardless of the 90k or is this on top
of
that no the that's it as well I G I have
a checking account with like my I keep
my weekly pay or my bi-weekly pay in
that checking account just use that
great so how much will you be making
going
forward uh it's about $1,000 uh it's
about $2,000 a month going forward okay
do you get also expenses taken care of
or are you required to take care of your
own
expenses uh yes for the next five months
at least my living is taken care of uh
two out of my meals are taken care of
and so I really my only expenses right
now are groceries gas and whatever I
want to do for fun all right what
happens after the five months because
this is going to dictate what George is
going to coach you on what happens after
that five
months um I would either have to move
back well right now I'm renting out a
house so I would have to either move
back into the team sanctioned hotel or I
would uh be set up at an apartment
complex at like one of our Affiliates
where I'd be playing when you say set up
are they pay
yes my living can be taken care of after
this next five months good good good
good all right as well as
meals you at least two out of three yeah
okay that's good so it's going to really
limit your expenses going forward which
is wonderful as long as you have this
career okay well well without getting
into the particulars he's in the early
stages as far as professional baseball
yeah yeah yeah he's got he's got quite a
path if if things get better I mean
you're in the minor leagues right now
I'm guessing is right yeah that's
correct yeah yeah so as he moves up
obviously he could get a really large
contract but as long as he's in the
minors the actual pay is not very big
yeah so right it could be a very long
journey so I would just the sign on
bonus is great but we also have to
manage this well because you may end up
needing some of this that's correct the
line Sorry CJ I'm I'm catching him up on
this that helps me Ken is my sports uh
historian he helps me with this stuff
thank you Ken So you you're in a great
place financially already are there
expenses coming up that you know you're
going to have to pay for like a car
repair or upgrading the car things like
that uh a flight I know I'm definitely
gonna have to pay for a flight soon but
that's I mean that's three to 400 bucks
great so the key here is we got to
continue living on less than we make we
don't want to go use this sign on bonus
to just go buy a $90,000 car on vacation
what about taxes uh taxes are another
thing we have to be thinking about is
this going to be taxable income I assume
you're going to owe 25 30% on 40% uh
it's it's already been it's been taxed
already but I'm still learning I'm still
learning taxes and everything so I'm
sure there's something I'll have to pay
I would connect with a a ramsy trusted
tax pro at Ramsey solutions.com and they
can help coach you through this to make
sure because what I don't want is you
wake up to a huge tax bill that you're
not prepared for that eats up all of
this money right so for now CJ I'm going
to leave this in a high yield savings
account and I would continue to invest
out of your paychecks is there some sort
of retirement plan provided or are you
on your own for
that I'm on my own for that okay and for
that you may want to reach out to a a
smart Vestor Pro these are investing
Pros that can help you with the
investing Journey but a Roth IRA is
always a great place to start when you
have earned income as long as you're not
above the income limit and so you could
fund one of those with this 990,000 just
get a head start if you haven't been
investing at all okay and if you haven't
been investing at all so Roth IRA is a
good place to start Roth IRA yes and as
long as you're I I imagine you're under
the income limit right now you could be
getting close with this 90k sign on so
again check on your grow your adjusted
gross income for the year and if you're
able to contribute to that it's a great
place to start I believe for 2024 it's
now $7,000 you can contribute a year and
within that the raw Ira is just a shell
CJ you want to actually buy funds within
that and I would not recommend single
stocks what you're looking for here is
good growth stock mutual funds and uh
our team will send you a resource for
that I've got a video called investing
for beginners on YouTube that walks
through all of this and that will help
you out immensely as you start this
journey but at 21 CJ if you continue to
live on less than you make you invest
15% of your income you never touch debt
you're going to be so unbelievably
wealthy and you're just getting started
with this
career yes right so
thank you all so much for the uh for the
advice I look into Roth IRAs and not the
single stock but what's the other one
Mutual Funds growth stock mutual funds
is what that just means a giant pool of
stocks like 90 to 200 stocks in one
bucket so that you're Diversified
because you don't want all of your eggs
in one basket when it comes to investing
right and uh CJ can I you don't have to
answer this you don't have to answer
this I gotta ask are you uh are you
allowed to tell us your position or
would you rather
not yeah I'm a pitcher oh oh wondering
so okay what's your best pitch what's
your go-to pitch that's a fastball baby
that's a fastball yeah the high yeah I
know about the fastball do you know
about the fast I played a little uh MLB
2000 back in my day Ken CJ knows what's
up go CJ man that's awesome listen man
we're we're cheering for you and George
let me tell you this if CJ keeps
advancing as a pitcher we're talking
he's going to call back one day with a
lot of zeros he's going to be like I'm
buying my seventh rental property let me
tell you George the pictures make the
big bucks that's I'm proud of him yeah
good job CJ well keep at it buddy take
care of your body ignore all your
buddies who are like out buying really
expensive stuff cuz they just got the
signing bonus that's going to be the
hardest part for you is avoiding the
distractions and to help you with that
I'm going to send you a copy of my brand
new book called Breaking Free from broke
there's a great chapter on investing
traps in there there's a chapter called
wealth is patience that's going to teach
you all the stuff I just outlined so I
hope that helps you along this journey
and helps you avoid mistakes this is the
book people wish they read when they
were 21 CJ so hang on the line Austin's
going to pick up we will send you a link
to the Investing For Beginners video as
well as a copy of my book Breaking Free
from broke all right honest question
George how fast what's the fastest pitch
that you think you could even just get
the bat around and touch the ball forget
hitting it solid just you could get
around on it and and make contact how
fast what's the fastest oh like if
someone threw a 70 m per hour pitch you
paying attention to what we've been
talking yeah I mean I'm going to be
modest what do you think what's the
fastest pitch you think 40 mph 40 mph is
that reasonable that's ridiculous you're
saying I couldn't do it you should be
able to 40 mph is not that fast I wanted
to go modest well that was ridiculous
could you hit could you hit a
70 I'm going to say I could get around
on 70 for sure I could get around on it
whether I hit it squarely I think we
could still probably hit an 80 mph pitch
we'll see I think we should I play a lot
of pickle ball let's hit the old Diamond
Ken let's see what you got let's do it
that puts this hour of the ramsy show in
the books I'm George camel he's Ken
Coleman we'll be back before you know
[Music]
[Applause]
it
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm Ramsey personal George
camel joined by my esteemed colleague
Ken Coleman esteemed today very esteemed
and we are so pumped to take your calls
about money about work about your life
5225 if you've got a question about that
job opportunity the job you feel stuck
in what you're really meant to do what
you're wired to do Ken is the man for
those questions and he can expertly
guide you through that if you need to
just make more income we talk about how
your greatest wealth building tool is
your income and if you need more shovel
uh cuz you got the big hole you you're
in some debt and Ken can help you make
more money and find some opportunity for
you there so uh we are here for you to
serve you this hour at triple 8825
5225 Lydia is up first in St Louis Lydia
what is happening hi hi thank you for
taking my call I just had um a question
we are my husband and I currently have
our own business um and in addition to
that he just has took up a part-time job
at our church now that he's on staff
they have offered us um a free house to
live in you know as long as he has a job
um and so we do currently own a house we
got a really good interest rate on it um
like
2.4% and so we kind of hate to Let It Go
but we do not have savings other than
$1,000 in emergency fund and um we
currently have $220,000 of debt so we're
trying to figure out what the smartest
move for us would be is this our chance
to um just you know pay off all of our
debt and just kind of get in a better
situation and then just save the money
that we make off of the sale of the home
to eventually buy another home when
we're in a better financial situation is
it worth taking the risk to rent our
house out without any savings um just
what would be the smartest move how much
Equity do you have in the home if we
sell it right now we would make
30,000
and that's after fees yes okay and that
would pay off your debt and give you
half an emergency fund most
likely it would pay off the debt and we
would have 10,000 left over okay and I'm
guessing three to six months of expenses
for you guys is at in the ballpark of 15
to 20 based on your expenses um it would
be yeah 30 probably okay so it would
definitely speed up your progress along
the baby steps and uh I do agree with
you that you're adding a lot of Risk by
becoming you know landlords here while
having zero in the bank that's going to
be real stressful making that transition
and so I understand you don't want to
let go of the the lower interest
mortgage rate but you're just going to
add stress on the other side and so sure
I do think it's a clean slate for you
guys just to live in this house get some
Financial footing and there's always
going to be another house down the line
uh but you're going to be in a different
financial position you're going to have
way more to put down you're not going to
be as worried about the interest rate
because you're going to be able to pay
that house off really early so I like
this plan of just getting rid of this
thing and moving on with your life and
figuring out down the line now this free
housing is there stipended or if you
don't take it or is it just free housing
or you don't take it it's completely
free and if we don't take it then we
just don't take it there's no additional
benefit got it and there's a cover
utilities as well everything wow yeah
that's hard to pass up yep I would do it
I would list the house this afternoon
that's for a part-time job at the church
they're offering this yes goodness
that's amazing so my other my other
question then if we were to sell the
house um are you saying that we should
take the sale like the money that we
would make off of the sale of the house
and put that just directly toward debt
or we're projected to pay off our debt
by the end of this year as is um or
should we just keep paying our debt as
we are and then after that as soon as
that money hits your account you're it's
you're never going to see the money
essentially it's going to go towards the
debt and whatever's left is going to go
sit in a high yield savings account as
your um starter emergency fund as you
continue to build it yeah and Lydia
let's walk through the numbers you just
gave us if you pay the $20,000 off you
still have 10,000 you said you're on
track to pay the 20,000 off by the end
of 2024 and you said 30,000 was the
number so that means we're debt free
instantly
and then by the end of the year we have
a fully funded emergency
fund that's the order that's the way we
that George and I would do that do you
understand yes that's great you're
getting to freedom and stability Faster
by doing it this
way okay and I don't think it's worth
the risk of renting this place out
you're not going to make much spread
probably because of the mortgage and
what you're going to rent it for on top
of one thing going wrong and you guys
can't cover it putting you further into
debt cuz the first time they do
something or you can't prove they did it
or something happens guess who pays for
that
repair us of course sell the house
immediately immediately upon deposit as
George said pay off the 20,000 put 10 in
savings and keep going on the debt plan
except now that's going into savings to
get us to three months of expenses or 3
to six whatever it is and then now you
guys are rocking and rolling and just
keep stacking cash in the form of baby
step 4 uh once you get to that stage
while you're getting that Free Housing
come on this is a great situation all
right let's go to Alexander in Dallas
Alexander welcome to the
show hello um I was calling to ask you a
question uh I'm trying to pay off my car
I'm not exactly sure if I should just
keep chipping away at it or not or if I
should um do some other drastic move to
get rid of that I currently ow 20 on it
and it's worth about eight or
9,000 okay that's uh almost all the debt
I have I have like 300 other dollars in
debt all right what car is this it's a
2015 Subaru Forester and have you
checked Kelly Blue Book private party
value yes the private party value is
about 12 or so okay the and the trade in
is about eight or nine yeah that's
that's my issue is trade in you're
you're not going to get high dollar for
this and so the closer we can get to the
amount of loan that you owe the better
so how much money do you have in the
bank right
now uh currently have uh
$1,000 about or something like that but
that's all ex uh set aside for expenses
and stuff and what is your
income uh it's about 40,000 so about um
4,000 a month you bought a lot of car
for making 40,000
yeah I bought it when I was making less
so yeah we need to get rid of this thing
but you're going to need to come up with
the difference that you're underwater on
so you got two options to do this one is
you can go to your your credit union or
go to the place that holds the loan and
say listen you got some bad collateral
here cuz this thing's worth nine I owe
20 can you give me an
$11,000 loan to make up for the
difference and I get rid of this car now
obviously you need another car so you
probably need to save up a few thousand
before you do this the other option is
you go out and save up
$67,000 to cover the difference yourself
with cash which is a great option but it
may take a little while as you continue
chipping away but there's no fun way to
do this either way this car has got to
go I would not hang on to
it all right sorry for the bad news
Alexander but those are your two options
so I would try to get that personal loan
to at least eliminate some of this debt
and get out of this underwater car but
either way it's going to involve some
sacrifice and uh it's an expensive
lesson to learn but man car loans are
killing people with these underwater
situations Alexander hate to hear that
you're going through it this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show hey guys ramsy solution started
small and grew fast because of that
rapid growth there were times when our
systems slowed us down that's why we
switch to net Suite it works for us and
it'll help your business too whether
you're starting on a card table like I
did or you're well on your way to
becoming a multi-million dollar company
netsuite can scale with you and help you
communicate and plan better because you
know your day-to-day up and down and
sideways but accounting analytics and
supply chain are on another level so
maybe you're just not techsavvy that can
be okay net Suite will help at your
speed and whatever your situation more
than
37,000 companies use netsuite to know
their numbers and their business better
so check out netsuite today and find out
how they can help you become the
business you want to be 5 or 30 years
from now and right now you can download
Net's free kpi checklist designed to
give you consistently excellent
performance at netsuite.com Ramy that's
netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Ken Coleman if
you enjoy the show we'd love if you do
us a favor and share it subscribe
wherever you're listening hit the follow
button leave us a review and just tell
people about it maybe that's a text
maybe you hit the little share button
and uh send a link to a certain episode
or clip that you loved but you guys are
the best marketing plan we could ask for
and it's one of the reasons we hit
number one out of all podcasts on Apple
podcast earlier the fact that my mom uh
figured out a way to hack the system and
clicked on the thumb a lot that's
amazing yeah Barb I need to ask karb how
she accomplished that I don't know I
don't know she wanted her boy to to hit
it hit the big time so just her and may
camel just really hitting that like And
subscribe button how is it that Barb and
may have not met they need to they'd get
along they really would mifly is that a
word is it ever mously you're welcome no
mifly mously yeah boy I got to tell you
you've been working hard because I don't
ever remember you pulling a word out if
I can teach old dog a new vocabulary
word I'm doing something wrong all right
I'm going to look that up on the
commercial break but Jordan awaits or
what are we doing right now are we doing
doing a little do we have a little 401K
yeah I have a little teach excited right
oh I apologize George teach away don't
jump the gun here so here's the deal Ken
we get this question a lot and I wanted
to address it because a lot of people
are going through this right now they're
leaving jobs we've seen a huge migration
of just people moving around do I do
with my 401k what do I do with behind
yes oh this is a big question so it's
it's a big one and it's important one
that has a lot of zeros on the end so I
want to walk people through the thought
process uh when it comes to Rolling over
the 401K so of course you have a bunch
of options number one is cash out your
401K which is a terrible idea because
you're going to pay taxes and penalties
if you're not of retirement age the
other option is do nothing and leave the
money in your old 401K also a terrible
idea probably in second place in the
terrible idea list the other two options
are you can roll over the money into
your new employer's plan so if you have
an old 401k you got a new job you can
roll it directly into the new employer's
401k and then finally the last and
probably my favorite option is you can
do a rollover into an IRA which is
outside of an employer and so I like
that one the best can because it gives
you the most control over your investing
options the IRA basically has unlimited
options whereas your 401k has a fewer
more select options all right so let's
play this out excuse me I leave company
ABC and I have a 401k there and so I
take a job in another company and
they've got a 401k plan I'm going to go
to my um to my smart Vestor Pro my the
person handles my my retirement I'm
going to say all right I need to take my
Cur my old 401K I need to roll that over
into an IRA and I'm going to jump right
in immediately with the new
401K yeah and so that 401k from the
previous company is going to grow you're
just not contributing to it but it's
going to sit in that amount in the ira
or can you choose to contribute to it in
the ira form so with you know that's
called a rollover Ira so that is an
option where you that money continues to
grow you can continue to contribute and
so that is a a solid option because of
the amount of control you have over your
Investments and I like that one the best
because as a bucket when you think about
your retirement plan it's good to have
different buckets right and if it's
here's the big thing though people don't
think about if you had a Roth if you had
a traditional 401k plan and you decide
hey I'm going to do a rollover to our
Roth IRA you don't want to do that
because that's there's going to be Roth
conversion that you pay that's right and
the only time you should do that is when
you're in baby step 7even you have a
paid for house now this is extra money
you have laying around and you can pay
the tax burden to basically con convert
that to taxfree there's no purpose in in
in taking a 401k and putting it in a
Roth because you're going to pay a tax
and that's the whole purpose of having a
Roth is to get it out later with no tax
you want that money to grow taxfree so
there's a time in place to do that but
you're going to pay a hefty fee in order
to do that and that's why we do the IRA
you want to do a direct rollover so
let's say you have a traditional 401K
you want to do a direct rollover to a
traditional IRA right if you have a Roth
401k you can do a direct roll over to a
Roth IRA so you want to keep them
equally yolked if you will like keep it
biblical for you can I know you like
that reference thank you thank you for
the reference so if you've got the old
one it's time and uh you you got to do
something don't just leave it sitting
out there you don't have control over it
the fees are now eating up what was left
of your nest egg there so do something
roll it over to the new employer or roll
it over direct roll it rolling rolling
direct is what you want not indirect Ken
direct to avoid any fees equally yoked
you don't want to see that money yeah
that's the important part so if you have
questions about this you can of course
ask your employer and HR department but
you can also get an investment Pro in
your corner and uh if you go to Ramsey
solutions.com our smartvestor program
can get you in touch with someone who
can help you with this rollover process
that's something I did K when I worked
at uh Ramsay had an old 401k from my
Apple retail days and so they helped me
roll that over into an IRA and that
money's been growing ever since from a
Roth 401k direct rollover Roth IRA I
love it and it's been growing with with
my control so I love it no reference to
my rolling rolling roll nothing I didn't
want to acknowledge it to be honest why
was that a old Walmart ad no it's not an
old Walmart ad it's just an is it an old
Walmart those prices roll I heard
biscuit reference it's not limb biscuit
Joe Joe knows it's an old song uh
rawhyde uh like a western it was a
western Rawhide yeah like an old I mean
George you wouldn't know what it is
because you don't even know who John
Wayne is but I dig yeah no it is RA by
Frank ra we just went the whole range
there but uh that's what I do I like to
create good conversation over absolutely
nothing I think that tells you the the
Zeitgeist that we were born into Ken
you're mentioning songs from 1961 and
I'm thinking did you pull it up well
give him the full reference now people
want to know Raw Hide by Frankie Lane
Raw Hide by Frankie Lane released in
1961 that see this is you're smarter now
you're smarter I don't care if you like
it or not but let's help Jordan out can
you admit your references are a bit
dated well there's a question their data
but that's the spice that I bring to the
show you and Rachel don't know about
anything since like
2000 we don't know what deloney knows
what's going on inside his head is just
just dangerous I got to bring a little
bit of culture a little bit of uh
knowledge I bring some vocab you bring
some culture and we meet in the middle
listen I love it nobody's complaining
about the Rawhide reference plus I think
people want to hear me sing more oh gosh
I could be wrong about that one no we
want to hear from Jordan and Missoula
love that place Jordan what's going on
hi thank you so much for taking my call
I appreciate it sure what's going on I
first of all I enjoy the banter between
you you both it's pretty comical see
James people like it see James James is
always honest about about the banter and
Jordan likes it so there you go well
Jordan we like you well thank you so
much so my question is um I've been
following you know the baby step stuff
for quite a while and I'm I'm
considering upgrading my truck my
question is um should I just cool my
Jets and be patient and content with
what I have or you know based on where
I'm at financially is it reasonable for
me to consider an upgrade um just a
quick background um no no debt other
than my mortgage um my house is worth
roughly 450k and we owe 180 on it uh
15-year fixed rate mortgage um I make
120k a year gross um and my wife's a
stay-at-home mom our other vehicle is is
a paid for Honda Pilot that's worth
roughly 30 and I would consider spending
30 on this new truck uh my current truck
is 20 years old I can maybe get 10 grand
for it it's starting to show a little
bit of signs of breaking down um so
considering just keeping that thing
until it just completely dies or maybe
splurging and and getting something a
little nicer so we're talking 20K we'll
get you this truck and exactly yeah I'm
doing it today yeah I
agree well that was easy yeah well
listen you did a first of all you did a
really good job of laying out the facts
every Ramsey Show caller should study
your model that was fantastic you laid
it out perfectly you've got the money
you got the value you've lived like no
one else and so now you're you went from
int to intentional in baby steps 456
you've got this mortgage you're chipping
away at diligently but it's okay at that
point to go on the vacations and splurge
and upgrade the car you're doing it with
cash and you're right there in our
parameter where your the total of all
things with motors and wheels adds up to
half of your annual income so between
the pilot and this truck you're getting
you're right there at about half of that
120 at 60 and so you're doing it the
right way Jordan what kind of truck is
it what is it what so I probably would
get a a Toyota Tundra I'm not totally
sure still and the the the researching
phase I like to nerd out look up a bunch
of stuff I just rode in Winston Cruz's
Toyota Tundra oh you did let me tell you
Ken name I think I'm a tuck I'm a truck
guy now so way to go Jordan love that
for you you're doing it the right way
man living like no one else and now
driving like no one else yeah paying
cash selling the other truck it's going
to be a 20K Gap he's got the money this
is what we like to see America smart
decisions very exciting nice new
truck and we're off the air
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being being accepted
the home buyer Edge from Churchill gives
you an advantage over those other guys
go to Churchill mortgage.com today to
learn
[Music]
more
this is the Ramsay show I'm George camel
joined by Ken Coleman the number to call
is
5225 up next we've got bill in New Haven
Connecticut Bill how's it
going hi thank you for taking my call
sure um my wife and I are in a very
difficult
situation I'm 71 I'll be 72 next month
my wife is 66 she teaches at a private
school we moved
from uh a state where the salaries are
considerably lower than they are here in
Connecticut and the cost of living is
not a whole lot
different
and um this past summer and the Heat of
the summer for Connecticut our air
conditioning went out
completely and it's it's going to cost
us almost
14,500 to get a new uh furnace and
everything uh to replace the one that
went that went out and uh that's going
to you we they have a state program here
I can Finance it'll be almost one be
about a 1 175 a month for 10 years
additionally my wife took out a parent
loan for our daughter to go to college I
was adamantly opposed to it
but you know her philosophy is she's my
baby and I love her so I'm going to do
it and due to being in forbearance twice
once due to being to getting sick and
having to take off work during the
school year in the other state and
um and then moving
uh up here to
Connecticut uh she went into for
barrance each of those two times and
what that means is that you don't have
to make a payment but the interest acrs
as a result she still owes over
$100,000 on that our yes our daughter
went to a private school in New
York and uh yes uh it's like I've been
fighting a losing battle financially all
these years and I'm 71 now I'll be 7 to
next
month and I have to go back to
work um you know I took an early
retirement a few years ago but you know
all I'm getting is a small social
security check because my salaries were
always low I have a a small Army Reserve
retirement thank goodness I stayed in
that for over 20 years and then I have a
very very small State retirement from
our most recent State uh worked for the
State Retirement System uh for a few
years so what is what do the household
income add up to right
now our total
income our AGI is less than 100,000 okay
putting
everything and my wife is 66 and she
would like to start receiving Social
Security when she can get the maximum
dollar amount and I would like for her
to do that too but she's talking about
starting to receive Social Security as
soon as she can which I believe is
about another six or months or so
something like
that and uh it would be considerably
less and she teaches at a private school
now she's happy there the salaries at
private schools are very
low but she says at her age
if she were to get a Connecticut
teaching certificate nobody would hire
her because who wants a who wants a uh
66 year old woman I don't buy that one
well that's what she
says and uh plus she she loves where she
is now she was in a miserable teaching
situation uh in the previous state
that's why she went on sick leave
because
the superintendent
drove her to that to make a long story
short and then we moved up here and so
due to those two situations is why she
went on the forbearance because we did
not have any money coming in to make the
payments now I'm looking at at going
back to work whether it's full-time or
part-time preferably full-time because
like I said I need the money how much do
you guys have that's liquid liquid cash
oh nothing
we have bills up to our eyeballs you
have more debt than the parent Plus
loans and this 145 HVAC yes what else
yes credit cards of course and it's
about $770,000
goodness gracious yes I know I know it's
it's horrifying and I'm is your wife
concerned about this or is it just you
absolutely yes both of us are concerned
and what what other
debt well the house what's left on the
mortgage oh
gee probably about well 200 and
something thousand okay what's the house
worth
uh I don't know we're not sure about
that it's
about what did you buy it
for I'm trying to remember we bought it
for 3,000 something uh 300 ,000 and
something okay uh now I'm like I said
I'm looking at going back to work and I
know that some of the places I've come
across mention in their ads that they
offer
401ks some mention that they offer 401K
is worth a match some do not mention a
401k at all now my understanding is that
you have to begin withdrawing from a
401k at a certain age and I'm wondering
if at my age would I even be allowed to
put money into a
401k and uh if I did what would I do put
the put the money in the 401K and get
the employer match and then start
withdrawing the
401K well truthfully Bill Bill I don't
want to be there bare bad news but we
got a waste to go before we would even
begin investing so we wouldn't recommend
you do any investing until you clean up
this
mess even with the uh even with the
employer match even with the employer
match you guys are so underwater on
payments you don't have a dime to invest
you're exactly right so we need to clean
up this debt and so I'm going to start
with the smallest balance the larg just
I'm going to try to can your daughter
make the payment on these student loans
she won't do it why she says it's the
parents responsibility to pay for the
child's education I pay for my education
who taught her that
mom uh how did you guess oh my goodness
well okay so Bill here's the reality
you've been catered to her whole life
well this is as much a marital problem
as much as Financial yeah You' got some
resentment towards towards your spouse
yeah you you got a marriage issue and
George and I can't solve the marriage
issue unfortunately the marriage issue
has created a mountain of money issues
and um bill look here's the bottom line
we teach the baby steps for a reason
whether you're 71 51 or 31 and right now
what you have to do is $1,000 as an
emergency fund and unfortunately you had
a massive emergency in the form of an
HVAC system you got to take care of that
George that's uh that's a tough
situation uh you can't you can't use
credit cards to do that um but you guys
are going to have to scramble and work
and uh it's time for you and Mom to have
a conversation with the daughter and
it's time for her to grow up that's
going to be a difficult convers ation if
your wife is as concerned as you said
she is then it's time for her to have
some hard conversations this is a mess
yeah I mean you're looking at 200,000
outside of the mortgage that you guys
owe if you're taking on these Parent
Plus Loans while making 90 and you're
already almost 72 Bill and so we've got
to make some big decisions you got to go
make 25 bucks an hour at least 40 hours
a week to help but you need your wife on
the same page first you're not going to
make any progress when you're trying to
do this on your own and you need to that
hard conversation with your daughter and
say listen mom and dad are broke and if
unless you want to be taken care of us
for the next 20 years we need to clean
up our mess and you need to clean up
these student loans but again the legal
responsibility is on you guys which is
the worst part about these Parent Plus
Loans Ken High interest rates
forbearance the kid doesn't pay it's on
the parents and uh Thanksgiving dinner
is real awkward Bill I'm so sorry you're
going through this man I hope that you
can clean this up and one day retire
again but this time the right way with
some dignity with some peace with some
patience and with a pile of money this
is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
I'm George Campell joined by Ken Coleman
this is the ramsy show the number to
call is8
825-5222 and your life will help you
take the right Next Step Daniel is in
Raleigh welcome to the show Daniel how
are you
doing hey thank you guys so much for
having me I'm I'm a big fan we
appreciate that what's your question
today of course so I'm 18 I'm a freshman
at UNCC and I'm studying Business and
Entrepreneurship cool um I own my own
business and I've been having
difficulties being able to do a good job
both running my business and also doing
a good job in school what's your
business we are an event entertainment
company we specialize in balloon animals
and face paint cool are we talking like
kids birthday parties carnivals like
what are your main gigs we do some kids
birthday parties we do lots of festivals
restaurant work um we work with some of
the sports teams in North Carolina like
the Panthers and the Hornets cool
um yeah all right and how successful has
this business been and how much time are
you putting into it it's it's been
pretty successful I started it when I
was 12 and for five years I was
practicing and getting to be the best
balloon twister I could um and I've
hired up a team to help me run this
while I'm in college um last year in
2022 we only made
$2,200 but this past year we were able
to make over $25,000
great and that's net profit yes yes
wonderful and you're saying hey this is
a lot for me to run while I'm in college
yes sir yes okay and how how many
classes are you taking like how many
hours are you devoting to school and how
much free time do you have right now I'm
devoting about probably 30 to 40 hours
to school um and another 30 hours to my
business um and it's just kind of a lot
while I'm also trying to be social and
have a good time in college so so the
question I have is is this a long-term
business play for you or is this
something you kind of started it's
throwing off the cash and you kind of
enjoy it I mean what's the strategy here
with this business as it is
today I I I'm enamored with what I do I
I love making balloons for a living it's
a lot of fun I want to do it for life um
this is a business I want to own and
grow to hopefully be a national change
someday um and we've been growing really
well this year and last year and this is
what I want to do with my life um and
I'm going to school for a chance to
learn how to better grow my business
while also getting to have fun while
getting an education well so you've got
you mentioned three things you've got
school you've got the business and
you've got a social life it doesn't
sound like you can do all three of those
to the level that you want so you got to
start going okay let me reverse engineer
this what's most important longterm and
that's going to determine what's most
important in the short term and I I'm
not trying to be koi with the answer but
it's like okay maybe I don't take as
many classes I can still pursue the
degree I'm not in any way telling you to
drop out of college but I'm saying
something's got to give or you do less
gigs with the business yeah that's the
other or you're less involved that's
right the business stays where it is for
now meaning it doesn't grow until you
have more time to give to it something
has to to give way
here that's true can you delegate more
to the team I can um I've hired up a
manager that will start I'm training him
in sales right now and that's a big
thing I've been dealing with is sales
for the business and taking the sales
calls and hopefully I'll have more time
to focus on other things whether that's
higher leverage opportunities for our
business or more time towards School I'm
not sure yet what is the thing that
you're most valuable in in the business
right now you just mentioned one aspect
you've been doing sales what's the thing
that only you can do right
now right now it's sales um but
hopefully soon it won't be um I'd say I
have a lot of the strategy for the
business I'm the one that makes the
instructional videos on how to learn
balloon twisting since we train our own
balloon
Twisters um so just I guess HR and
growing the team as well as finding the
customers and making the right decisions
to get customer
leads okay and who's paying for school
right now right now my parents are um
they're paying for the first year or two
um and I will be able I I won't have
issues paying for school afterwards
either so you have no debt and you have
a pile of money in the bank and you're
also putting money away that you're
making from the business yes sir I save
almost all of my income incredible
because that's an important piece of
this equation is not going into debt I
want to see you finish school if that's
a goal for you to get this degree that
will help you flourish in business and
it sounds like you want to do this
long-term full-time as soon as you're
out of school yeah so this is a
temporary you got what three more years
or you in the first year I'm I'm in my
first year I'm I'm a freshman yes so the
other question is how do we expedite
College can you take on more credits and
just Crush through this so you're 21
years old graduating to pursue this
business that's true might mean you slow
down in order to speed up and so that
might mean delegating it might mean the
business just doesn't go for a season
and that you got to be okay with that
because you're doing a lot at once right
now and I don't want to see your grade
suffer while the business suffers and
you end up not making progress on
either that's that's true that's that's
a good point I I appreciate it yeah um
so I'd sit down with the with the folks
that you have see what kind of hires you
need to make while making this business
sustainable cuz you don't want to eat
into all the profits trying to just keep
this business afloat to where it's not
really accomplishing anything for
you yes sir so that's that's some big
decisions to make at your age I'm proud
of you man you've done really well thank
you I I really appreciate it thank you
best of luck with the future anything
else we can help with yeah um so I've
been following you guys' baby steps and
I'm now on baby step five and I mean I'm
18 years old I don't have a wife or kids
and I don't even have a girlfriend so it
feels a little premature to start saving
for my child's college fund uh what
would you recommend doing once I make it
to baby step five and I'm not sure how
to move forward I would focus on a
homeown payment fund and that might just
be a general high yield savings account
and you put every extra dollar you can
into that high yield savings account and
it's sitting there making you four to 5%
uh the other thing you could do is open
up a Roth IRA and contribute to that and
Max went out for the year based on your
stage and based on the fact that you
told me you're going to graduate debt
free so I think both of those are wise
for your future goals CU when you
graduate adulthood is going to hit you
like a ton of bricks with bills and
you're going to want to do stuff and buy
a home one day and so to be ahead of the
game with no debt and a pile of money in
the bank dude you're going to be light
years ahead of your
peers that that's the plan thank you um
right now I have a about half of my
money saved in a high yield savings
account and half of my money saved in
the stock market specifically with Vu
and
RSP um how do I know how to allocate
money to reinvest in my business versus
allocate money for the stock market how
do I know where I should be investing
more of my money well I would look at
you know what the last year of business
expenses has looked for you what's
coming up in the next year for you know
hiring and we got to upgrade our
equipment and so that's the amount of
money I'd be starting kind of a syncing
fund and reserves for but outside of
that you've got the money set aside in
your savings account and so worse came
to worse you could kind of Rob Peter to
pay Paul in a sense to cover any
business expense but if you're running
this thing debt-free and you've got some
money to cover those equipment expenses
rentals whatever your needs are you're
in great shape as far as the business
and so unless it's making a new hire
which hopefully they're going to produce
enough Revenue to offset what they cost
you so that's going to be the goal
running this business I'm going to send
you a copy of Dave's book entree
leadership as well Daniel that's our
playbook for how Dave built this thing
from a card table in his living room to
the Ramsey Empire with over a thousand
team members in this amazing campus and
I think it will encourage you along the
way as you're actually hiring people at
18 years old I mean what an impressive
kid this is this is an adult and his
parents did a great job raising him well
he's asking right questions yeah I mean
certainly at 18 looking longterm like
this and having to make these kind of
tough decisions very entrepreneurial you
love seeing that in this generation and
um really interesting to see and you
know I I never want to push anybody to
drop out of college but at some point
how much what business training do you
need versus a true four-year degree
maybe even looking at more business
classes business training small business
things like that that's what I'd be
looking at love and Daniel if you ever
come buy ramsy Solutions I'd love you to
twist me a little camel balloon I think
that'd be fun what do you think Ken I
yeah I would actually love to see that
that puts this hour of the Ramsey show
in the
[Music]
[Applause]
books
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George Campell joined
by Ken Coleman and we are your host this
hour the number to call is
8825 5225 if you've got a question about
money work purpose your career job you
feel stuck in we are here to help you
take the next step8 825
5225 Adam kicks us off in Miami Adam
what is going on in
Miami hey thank you for having me sure
how can we
help yeah so um I I actually found out
today so this is kind of the reason for
my call I found out today that I uh owe
$31,000 in uh student debt and I know
that sounds a little crazy but the
reason is is because um so um I had I
guess two called two RS I guess um one
was a parent plus and that was taken
care of by uh that was forgiven because
of a GI bill and my family a little bit
dysfunctional um and kind of every time
I brought it up I would see in my credit
report this $31,000 and it's it was
actually 27 before that interest um and
it was just told that you know um it was
taken care of don't worry about it it's
wrong it'll be updated it just charged
and so I just kind of go a research
today and found out that it's totally
separate and it's in my name so you know
I I have to take care of it so basically
it's uh you know uh student loans spread
about 31,000 spread across nine uh loans
you know throughout the four years um so
I was just considering consolidating it
I just wanted you know kind of I don't
really know where to start so I was just
hoping to get some advice on how to
attack it well a rude awakening for sure
and I'm sure very frustrating and not
causing uh not causing any repair with
the relationship with your family that
told you hey don't worry about it we've
got it yeah exactly I was I was saving
up for a car so so where are you at now
do you have any other
debt no okay and how much money do you
have in the
bank um in investments in World Ira
about 10 and then in the stocks about 10
and about two or three um just um
sitting sitting in the night count okay
great so what's your
income um so my base is about 75 I
started a new job recently should be
could could could potentially be uh it's
hard to speculate but could potentially
be well over 100 wonderful okay so the
good news is in this mess is that you're
going to be done with this debt my guess
is within 6 months
I yeah i' love to hear how like
consolidated is that something you know
across like across those it's it's nine
summer nine loans ranging from two to
7,000 yeah I was in a very similar
position to you when I was 23 I did
pulled my credit report realized I had
36,000 in student loans across about 11
loans and the way I did it is the way
I'm going to recommend to you and that
is to not consolidate these debts cuz
all you're doing is just moving the debt
around into one big pile instead of tiny
piles so you didn't really do anything
you just have the illusion that you did
something so instead what I would do is
just attack the smallest one with a
Vengeance and I would also and this is
also something I did I would sell those
those stocks that you have yeah that's
not retirement right you just invested
in a bunch of stocks and it's at
10K yeah well it's a it's an acorns
account that I used okay so I would
liquidate that and I would move away
from single stocks anyways
and instead once you're debt free with
an emergency fund then I would begin to
invest 15% into tax advantage retirement
accounts and I would quit I wouldn't use
the acorns app if I'm in your
shoes yeah and I think that's going to
give you a better long-term future and
it's going to get you out of debt the
fastest cuz you told me you've got you
know 2,000 plus the 10,000 in stocks the
rest is retirement accounts in the
Investments yeah that's correct okay so
you've almost knocked out you know
you've knocked out a third and almost a
half of your student loans just by doing
this mhm so that that leaves you with
19,000 left you're going to make a 100
so the question is how quickly can we
pay off 19 making a 100 how much margin
can we throw at these debts from small
to largest balance ignoring the interest
rate yeah um that's definitely something
I have to figure out but you know I
definitely don't want to you know not
have anything in the bank um well you'll
have $1,000 you'll leave as a starter
emergency fund fund and then for 6
months what you're going to do is try to
throw $3,000 a month toward your
smallest debts and make minimum payments
on the
rest okay so 3,000 time 6
18 which is about what you'll have after
you sell the stocks put a little bit of
the money you have in savings and put
that all towards your debts that's going
to knock out almost half your student
loans you tracking yeah so you're going
to free up payments for that payment
gets rolled into the next debt along
with all the you're mustering up from
your income and I'm telling you man you
could be in a very different place 6
months from now and 6 months after that
you're going to save up a fully funded
emergency
fund three to six months of expenses you
would you wouldn't suggest at all like
going with you know monthly payments or
anything like that monthly payments on
what like well I guess I guess never
mind you know well I was just thinking
consolidating and turning into the
monthly payments but that's not the
right call so well it doesn't move you
forward I'm trying to help you move
forward and get rid of this this debt
instead of just move it and go well I
made it into one big payment cuz I can't
keep up with nine instead I found that
it was much more motivating for me to
see each net debt get knocked out one by
one freeing up a payment applying it to
the next one and the next one and with
doing this plan I'm telling you 12
months from now you're debt-free with a
fully funded emergency fund and you're
investing 15% of your income in
retirement if you do it your way you're
going to be calling back a year from now
I growing I I got I got to jump in here
Adam I know you understand what George
said but after he explained it really
clearly and you said you understood it
you jumped right back into the
consolidation thing it leads me to
believe that you've got some people that
are pretty influential in your life that
are pitching you on this and you're and
while you understand what George is
saying I'm not sure you believe it yet
am I right or am I wrong no you're wrong
I honestly don't really have anyone to
go to for financial advice okay good so
so listen do you believe then so so I'm
glad I'm glad I'm wrong but do you
believe that you can do what George is
saying yeah I I do I believe it's gonna
be very tough but that's that's very
possible all right dude I did not make
100K yeah I was making a starter salary
and I had more debt than you and I did
this in 18 months with some hustle I was
doing side hustles so you got to be
willing to sacrifice and you can do this
in six months and a third of the time
with this amazing income and with these
stocks you're going to sell that's right
and so you got to quit getting
distracted that's what's happening here
you're doing a lot of things at once and
you have an amazing
and yourest buol is your income and
right now it's being siphoned away from
student loans and your and distracting
distracted by acorns micro investing
apps and I talk about these investing
traps in the book and I specifically
call out ones like acorns because I
think they're these apps are designed to
take your money not make you money I I
would like to give the first book of
yours that I've given away right now an
honor Breaking Free from broke it's your
gift Adam I'm giving it to you but
George did all the work see how I did
that I like that hang on the line Austin
will get you a copy of that because
George you really do do a great job of
explaining the game that people are in
it's kind of like you're you're you're
breaking down the Matrix in this book
yes the financial Matrix and once you
see it you can't unsee it and I hope it
helps Adam break free from bro cuz he's
a wise young man making good money and I
want to see that money help him build
wealth instead of big towers in the sky
for Sally May so hang on the line Adam
we'll send you a copy of Breaking Free
from broke and wishing you the best with
that payoff this is the ramsy show
[Music]
a
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Ken Coleman the
number to call is AAA 825
5225 well let's get to the lines Lisa
joins us up next in my homeown Boston
Massachusetts Lisa welcome to the Ramsay
show thank you so much I really
appreciate this opportunity to discuss
and get your insights on this so
absolutely I I'm single I was recently
laid off I'm collecting Severance for
about the next 15 months I currently
rent as you know my rent continues to go
nowhere but up and I'm at a a pivotal
time in my life where I'm actually
thinking about relocating to an area
where I can afford to purchase a home
for around a price that will keep my
mortgage even lower than my rent and I
was looking for some insight and advice
on that okay hey so what what job did
you get laid off from what were you
doing I was in U media for a long time I
was fortunate you know they owe me
nothing I was there 25 great years but
it's a little bit scary now because I'm
little older in age and I'm not really
sure if I even want to do the big
corporate job anymore I I really would
rather do something more purpose and
volunteerism and I really can't see me
having that luxury if I continue to
chase rent so I was thinking about
relocating you know purchasing home I
can't as you know right can't get a
house from anywhere near Boston for
325,000 but I can if I relocate and I
was actually toying with although this
is where I'm looking for your Insight
over like about four years just
purchasing my home out right so in like
four years time I have no debt and at
that point I could afford to live on you
know my pension and my Social Security
and my remaining 401K that I don't touch
for my home
okay so where you thinking about moving
to Florida oh there you go all right
there you go yeah big change yeah but I
love the sun I'm not a cold person not a
skier I've always stayed here for my
family but I'm at a point now where you
know it's not a good enough reason to
keep me grounded I can continue to come
home and visit family they'll come to me
so I just think you know this maybe is
serving as a catalyst for me to do
something you know put my big girl pants
on which I never would have done before
and you know take that chance and move
and purchase a home I like about a lot
of what I'm hearing I am just curious
why you wouldn't continue to work uh
you've got a lot of
experience yeah I'm not saying I won't I
think it's I don't want the pressure of
having to go out and get what I had
right um you know I'm trying to be a
realist what did you have tell me a
little bit more like what were you doing
and what were you
making I was making about $140,000 a
year media what what sales sales sales
okay and so when you say you don't want
to go out and feel the pressure to get a
sales job making 140 is that what you
mean yeah yeah and I also have some
health things I might be facing um that
I might have to take a little bit of
time for myself I I was recently
diagnosed with you know an issue that
has to be addressed nothing lifechanging
but might need to take a little bit of
downtime for myself so you know because
of those factors I'm just trying to
think well what can I do to get myself
where I feel in a better situation that
I don't have to make this money and you
know I I have you know I guess it's all
relative in life I think I have a pretty
good um you know retirement strategy and
Savings in my
401k and liquid savings I don't have a
lot of debt but I also don't you know
I've been so disciplined and worked so
hard I don't want it because I'm now
suddenly faced with like a health thing
and losing my job that I panic and make
a really bad choice so that's why I was
calling into to you know to you
gentlemen because you know I'm big fan
of the show you mentioned you have
debt I have one debt I have a car
payment which I can easily pay off I I
just haven't because I was
working on the
loan uh 177,000 okay and how much money
do you have in
savings I have about 800,000 in a 401k
100,000 in in liquid savings and then I
have like a lump sum for better words
lack of better words that's I can take
out as a pension or I can roll over to a
401k that's a lump sum amount as well
okay great well Lisa I'm gonna answer
this is if I was in your shoes how old
are you 58 okay if I'm in your shoes and
you I really wanted to move to Florida I
would number one take some of this
liquid savings and pay off the SE the
car loan today okay now you're Deb free
it's going to free up a payment and then
here's the crazy part I would go rent in
Florida for a little while until I
figured out what was next and I would be
I would personally be looking for a job
so that I'm able to pay off this house
once I had the house paid off and I had
enough in retirement then I would go all
right Lisa's out and she's going to
maybe have an early retirement or an
encore career but I wouldn't just you
know pack it up and go to the uh you
know the 50s living community in Florida
Margaritaville I keep thinking of the
sign doesn't it that's actually no but
that's actually like a neighborhood in
Florida they're all over the country
look amazing it is well for that I've
been going to this area for a while guys
and I do love the area and I have
friends there so it's not a need
reaction from that perspective but more
of a excuse me can you rent over there
for a while the rent will be high the
rent will be high and I just the
Market's kind of going up my friends
bought two years ago and their house
doubled I'm almost a little pressured
where I feel like I know I can still go
buy a nice house for 325 so you would
buy a house for 325 and your down
payment would be the rest of your liquid
cash outside of an emergency fund I'm
thinking of not doing that I'm thinking
about just putting 10% down then over
four years withdraw the money from my
401k and pay it off
outright but you're going to be
unemployed and we need to pay a mortgage
now that's $300,000 have I have um I
I've already been pre-approved because
of my sance is and my 401k they do a
continuance program where I can
guarantee that I can pay it but what
happens when the sance is
over the severance is 16 months and I'm
sure I'll have a job by then it's no
different than if I'm here renting and
strapped down I I guess where I'm going
with this guys is I know if I own a home
and I get a job making half my money I
can say hey you know what I'm going to
pay $75,000 a year and just get rid of
this in its entirety now all I have is
my food and utility bills I can never
say that I we get where you're going I
don't think we like how you're trying to
get there in fact I know we don't like
how you're trying to get there but love
love where you want to go I mean if
you've got friends down there and you
could room roommate up you know for 6
months and do a short-term lease get on
the ground I know you visited a lunch um
or put put the rest of the what are you
going to have left after the car payment
17 you're going to have a what about
83,000 to put down ,000 well you know
look that's 20% down you know on a 3 is
is is that much you can leave the rest
as an emergency fund I would put as much
down as possible I would to put it all
down but you e you easily have the 20%
that we like to recommend yeah it'll
help you avoid PMI get a job I'm willing
to do
that do the 20% okay here's what I would
do I'm going to add to what George said
I would take a couple
months okay chill out right take care of
your health issue you're going to be
okay I take two months Max get down
there get the girlfriends you know have
some fun times you know throw the margs
back a couple nights but we're we're now
looking for a job down there we're going
to have a good time we're going to get
employed we're not going to use that
Severance to live off of I would be
stacking that Severance if if it were me
I'd be trying to only use a couple
months of that Severance George get
employed down there
and take the rest of that Severance and
plug it into the baby steps yeah well
Lisa you told us you don't want to be
pressured into getting back into the
sales job well you're going to feel
pressure when the severance is running
out and you haven't found that dream yet
so I'm going to start searching ASAP and
land that to give you some some cushion
and I want you to take as small of a
mortgage as possible because the goal is
to pay it off as quickly as possible and
it's going to reduce your mortgage
payment down the more you put down the
smaller the payment that's right less
pressure you have to go out and make 140
Grand and I don't think it'll be a
pressure situation with your personal
your sales experience you could crush it
down there Lisa sold us on this dream I
know she's got the sales skills George
and I are going to come down and uh
visit it's going to be great oh Kenny
boy and me and Margaritaville
Margaritaville it's going to be great
we'll hang out with the 50s somethings
what's that drink you like the Gumby
Slumber the Gumby Slumber that's a Ken
Coleman favorite right there Fantastic
look it up she'll have one ready for you
Lisa we're wishing you the best with
this next chapter of your life and of
course wishing you the best with these
health issues hope you can get them
taken care of and we'll see you in
Florida this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
this is the ramsy show I'm George camel
joined by Ken Coleman the number to call
is
5225 Hayden's up next in Dallas Texas
Hayden welcome to the ramsy
show how you doing great how are you I'm
doing good so my question is I'm 18
years old I'm still a senior in high
school
and I've figured out relatively before
my senior year started that I want to be
a large animal vet
and I know that it's going to be very
pricey and I don't have any money saved
up
for um College besides what I'm going to
get for sh showing my barrels barrels
which would be about like maybe 800
$8,000 and I have no idea how to go
about scholarships or anything like that
what's the price range uh I'm assuming
there are more than a handful how many
schools would train you in that and then
what's the range of price on that are
they all pretty
similar so the route that I was going to
go is I'm just going to go to my
local College um in my county and get my
Basics and go over to Commerce
which is around I think when I
calculated it
was
20,000 year I think it was okay so so we
need to be super crystal clear on that
and then you need to do a lot of
research to go how many large vet
schools are in the country and what are
my options there because 20,000 a year
how long is the program let's just say
it's 20,000 you need to be really sure
on what that number is first of all but
what how many years have we talking
about about 20,000 times what so that's
that's just the animal science and that
would be four years so we're talking
880,000 then
what uh it's either two or four years
for preet which I can either go to A&M
OSU or Tech Texas Tech to do why are
those the only three
options uh cuz those are the only ones
near me that I'm comfortable driving to
that has a vet um licens program so okay
so let's keep adding this up because
it's important to what we're going to to
walk through with you so so two or four
years how much is that how much is
that for what what was it the second one
I don't know what the first one was
something about animals and the second
one was preet preet how much is that
going to cost
preet um if I take it at A&M Commerce it
would be I think 20,000 as well I can
also total or per
year per year okay so you're talking 40
to 80k on top of that goodness gracious
and then you have actual vet
school yes you have to go through a
license how many years and how much
we're playing the same game here how
many years how much
let's let me look it up real fast
because I've not looked up that aspect
of it
so if I get accepted that's the
Hope yeah that's that's the hope it's
very hard to get
accepted
um all right I'll tell you what just for
our listeners it's like an accountant
getting the taxes done and I don't even
care what the number is it's
crazy yes it is it's 30 or 22,000 a year
okay for how many years another four
years we're not sure two to four it's
it's I think it's two for just a vet
license all right preet you can take a
two-year or a fouryear all right so
what's your what are you what are you
wrestling through how can we help
specifically because we're not going to
tell you to take a loan out for that
that's insane if you just play the
numbers out and you look at what you
would make your first year out your
second year out what your path to growth
is and you run the numbers on an
interest rate and what you're going to
be paying back you're going to find out
pretty quickly it's really not worth it
but most young people because we don't
teach and our culture to actually run
the numbers and think about what it's
actually going to look like when you get
out you've been told your whole life
that this is just this is the uh price
of entry and it is the price of Entry no
question but it doesn't have to be
loaned maybe we're going to get in that
field we're going to make a lot of money
and we're going to cash flow this uh but
you've got to think through this
scholarships what can you do you know
what are my options around the country I
don't care that you can't drive to some
place in Arkansas but if Arkansas's got
something and it's a lot cheaper I can
tell you this no animal owner cares
where he went to school and I promise
you the animal doesn't care but you as a
young man have got to look at this stuff
and go is this worth it is there another
way these are two big questions that you
don't have the answers to so I so to the
worth it part there is one one thing
that kind of makes me think it might be
worth it is after you get out and the
vet license you have to practice for a
little bit under a uh under a company of
course but the
USDA can give you a contract for three
years to go to a county they choose and
pay $25,000 a year off of your um
student loan debt and you can sign that
contract as how many years you need to
but there's some golden handcuffs there
cuz what are you going to be making
there it sounds like a you're not making
much I got news for you young man you're
not going to make a lot working for a
County vet in fact you're going to be
making the bottom of the barrel so
they'll pay you 40K and they'll pay off
25 year student loans that's a 65k deal
yeah you could probably go make more
than that
elsewhere yeah that's that that's
another thing that I've been thinking
about is also you make 40K working under
somebody you need to go talk to some
vets you got to figure out what vets are
actually making out there in your area
doing what you do and then figure out
okay is this still I want to pursue and
then how do I do it affordably and so
there's a few steps I'm going to send
you my book Breaking Free from broke CU
I've got a whole section on student
loans and how to go to college debt free
here's the spark notes number one you
got to take debt off the table Hayden
you got to say I'm going to do it
without debt no matter what when you
pre-decide that it changes the rest of
your decisions then we can talk about
college savings accounts choosing an
affordable school which might mean you
might need to move across the country
for this dream and you can't limit
yourself to these three schools that
might cost a pretty
penny then we get into applying for
scholarships and grants as if it's a
part-time job I'm talking 15 to 20 hours
a week you're applying for so many
scholarships and grants your head is
spinning you hear me and then you're
going also going to work part time while
you're in
school and all of this is going to help
you cash flow it and help you leave
without debt and that might mean it
takes longer but right now you're
looking at a 10year journey to become a
vet is that right yes sir and about
$200,000
yikes with this current plan heyden how
how sure if if you could do it for free
okay you wouldn't have any of this debt
and that was one option on the table
right now and then I I said to you but
I've got some other options that would
allow you to use what you do well to do
stuff that you like would you say I'm
not interested in that I want to work
with animals I mean how much of this is
Passion versus just a genuine kind of
I'm intrigued by it seems like it might
be fun because you're 18 awfully young
how well do you know that you want to do
this so pretty pretty well because 16 to
17 years old I had no idea like that's
when I was trying to figure out what I
wanted to do and I'm in FFA and I show
beas and they would have me go down give
shots to pigs cattle whatever and what I
was doing I was like this is actually
kind of fun taking care of these animals
um make sure they're okay and I've been
interning with a V okay good let me ask
you this really quick because our time
is short is it possible and if the
answer is I don't know that's okay but
I'd like for you to check into what
would a path look like if you were to go
work for a veterinarian at a lower
level and pay your way through you know
some lower level degree like would would
they be interested in paying some of
your education or reimbursing you is
that done at that level I would think
it's a pretty
uh we talk about the large animals I
would think there's a lot of demand yes
or
no
demand yeah I think there's like a 100
or like a I think it was
195% increase rate for
Veterans for
veterinarians yeah sorry I don't know
why is a vet it's okay here's what I'm
saying I would like you to see if you
could talk to some local veterinaries
like George is talking about um and get
an idea of Entry
and what they're making are they
interested in finding young people like
you who know they want to do it and
would they be willing to supplement your
your your education so where you don't
have to go out and get a loan for it I
would at least kick the tires on that
George you got a lot of homework to do
and uh Hayden we're going to help you
out I'm going to send you a copy of
Breaking Free from broke read chapter 4
on student loans this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
our scripture of the Day psalm 13 they
are like trees planted along the
riverbank bearing fruit each season
their leaves never wither and they
prosper in all they do Booker T
Washington said Excellence is to do a
common thing in an uncommon way good
stuff open phones at 88255 225 this is
the Ramsey Show I'm George camel joined
by Ken Coleman and we're about to be
joined by Walter in Raleigh North
Carolina what's going on
Walter hi thanks for having me on on the
show gentlemen sure um I have a I have a
better question uh than I have I've been
having in the past uh my wife and I went
from a dual income no kids family to a
single income one kid family uh with a
with a birth of a three month-old we're
on baby step six and we have an
outstanding balance on a mortgage of
around
220,000 the kicker is that I'm active
duty and I can't take on extra jobs my
wife is going to school
and we're cash flowing that and in about
two to three years we're going to have
to move somewhere we don't know where my
question is is it worth still paying
down as much of the principle as I can
uh when I know mathematically there's no
way that we'll be able to clear the home
or is there something else that we
should be uh like still in stor mode for
for an eventual
move well there's no stor on the way
right we got the one kid correct okay
and then when is your wife finishing
school uh in about two years okay what
will she be doing after that with the
degree uh environmental science cool all
right so back to your question about the
morgage there's a fallacy that paying
down the mortgage is like wasting money
in a sense if you're not going to pay it
off in full and I don't see it that way
because what you're doing is really
creating a forced savings plan so all of
the money you're paying into that is
built into the equity and when you move
and sell that property you're going to
roll over that Equity into the new home
that you
buy does that make
sense it does I'm just I'm I'm wondering
how much extra should I uh like I mean I
guess I can go with what what I'm
comfortable with but if we if we just
keep making the minimum payments on the
mortgage and just I I don't know just
kind of like keeps keep beefing up the
six-month emergency fund um could we
then just pay the principal later or is
it better to pay it to pay it
incrementally it's better to pay it as
soon as possible because your interest
is calculated every single month and so
the sooner you make that extra payment
the sooner the interest starts to get
knocked down more is being thrown at the
principal with each payment and that
allows you to make real momentum and
progress versus putting it aside and
waiting to do it at the end of the year
doesn't make sense and you're not at
risk of losing a job sounds
like no so we don't need more than a
six-month emergency fund you're going to
be employed you're not scared of work
and thank you for your service by the
way and so I feel good about you
continuing to pay down this mortgage and
just rolling the equity over and when
you're ready to buy a new house the
money's ready to provide for you right
there okay but that's what I did
personally Walter um even if you're
going to move I still tell people pay
down the mortgage it's a force Savings
Plan you guys don't have any debt you
have an emergency fund and you're
investing 15%
correct correct then the next move there
outside of putting some money away for
that um your child in a 529 plan or an
Esa or do they have some kind of GI Bill
they do wonderful this is an awesome uh
plan then and so next up is getting rid
of this mortgage what's your household
income 85 okay so my goal would be how
much can we because you're cash flowing
your wife's school as well or is that
covered
correct we're we're cash flowing to uh
her schooling okay so anything beyond
cash flowing I would be throwing at the
mortgage Walter and uh you're going to
be thankful when you sell that house and
you get so much Equity out of it to roll
into your next goal so good luck with
the move and again thanks for your
service Jenny's up next in Colorado
Springs Colorado what is going
on hey kenon George thank you so much
for taking my call I'm super excited to
talk to you what's
to get to the meat of the question I
have I've been in private practice uh
for a couple years doing counseling and
income is kind of um it's not consistent
I would say my husband's in sales so his
income is not consistent either I
accepted a job about a month ago to work
for a university doing
counseling um but this job has kind of a
clause where you can't do any outside
work um and the yearly salary is
72,000 so the main thing that I'm
worried about is us paying off our debt
with me going to a job where the income
is kind of capped and I can't work
outside of that income when you say work
outside is it in counseling or you
couldn't even drive for
Uber well so right now I do instacart
and door Dash um and you have to get any
sort of permission for outside work
other than counseling so I could
potentially if I got um permission from
like the dean and the Regents it's this
whole process that you have to go
through to get the permission but I
definitely couldn't do counseling on the
side that's fine I get that have you
already taken the job and started or you
just recently
accepted yes so Ken I'm glad that I'm
talking to you and George of course but
I accepted the job but it took about two
and a half months to get credentialed
for it so the start date is in a couple
weeks so you
can get out of it is that what I'm
understanding yes with you know with a
major feeling of guilt
and well let me just say this
disappointing them well you know what
credential me well again you got to do
what's best for you and so if this is
not the right decision I'm not saying
that it's not but if it's not the right
decision you don't compound a mistake by
making another one you know right uh so
the so what were you making before you
took this
job um so in private practice I can make
anywhere between maybe 60 and
90,000 a year just depending on my
client load case load all my expenses so
what drove you so what drove you to take
the university job more stability on the
number yes because both of our jobs are
inconsistent and this the university job
has benefits it's more consistent
okay have to on all right so I'm going
to keep hit rapid fire here because we
got about two minutes and I want to be
able to help you uh yeah how much money
let's say that the university
automatically rubber stamped your side
hustles how much money would you want to
make where you go okay man that's
awesome Ken they said I could do this
and we need to make this much what's
that number beyond the 72 that you'd
want to make on the
side um I think realistically I could
probably only do like a thousand a month
for the side hustles but would you be
excited to have that additional 12,000
or would would that would that even make
a
dent um it wouldn't quite make a dent we
are about what's the goal of making more
you see where I'm going here so we're
we're scratching our head about making
12,000 that wouldn't make a dent and to
George's Point what's what do we need
the additional income for out of your
side hustles what do we need it
for um you mean on top of the income
that I have already and top of your 72
why go ahead just to make more of a dent
on our debt because we're about 750,000
in debt well how much is that as
mortgage uh$ 490 whoa what's the other
part I
know um two cars student loans personal
loans um my student loans are about 130
so I have my Master's what does your
husband do for a living he's in sales so
he sells still buildings how much are
your cars worth
um we're a little upside down in one of
them but the loans on those are about
40,000 20 each okay and what's your
household
income um make anywhere between yeah I'd
say 60 for him 70 if he's doing really
good okay because we're Joe I'm gonna
give this to George for you got to
follow the baby steps you're familiar
with the baby steps yes oh yeah okay so
so here's the deal your husband is in
sales in Colorado Springs only making
60,000 he needs to sell something that
he can make a whole lot more
money you you are listen you work
yourself silly with the limited time you
have and make $112,000 that's like
throwing a pebble in the ocean he needs
a six figure sales job and working
weekends and everything else you need
the stability and the benefits for where
you are now you guys got to clean up
250,000 of Consumer Debt sell the cars
everything we always say but he needs to
go make a whole lot more money he's
selling the wrong things and not enough
love it yeah we got a big hole here and
we got to get that shovel to match up
that puts this hour of the ramsy show in
the books I'm George he's Ken thanks to
all the folks in the booth and you
America will be back before you know
[Music]
[Applause]
it
[Music]
yeah